today we learned that visas issued one
of its coveted principal memberships for
the first time ever to a cryptocurrency
exchange in this case coin base will now
be able to issue its own credit cards
that let its customers spend Bitcoin
ether XRP and any of nine crypto
currencies anywhere that visa is
accepted previously this would have only
been possible with the support of a
third party that takes its own cut of
the process continuing in the tradition
of cryptocurrency removing unnecessary
middlemen from global finance visa
allowing coinbase
to issue its own credit card is further
breaking down borders further removing
those middlemen and helping create a
truly global economy recently I had a
chance to sit down with the co-founder
and CEO of coin base Brian Armstrong to
hear a little bit more about how he sees
the future if coin based pulls off what
it's set out to achieve just having
people be able to buy and trade those
coins is a good first step even further
can we help people actually gonna use
those points I think more about things
like how do we have not just 30 million
people who signed up to trade but how do
we have 100 million a billion people who
are now participating in the crypto
economy so what's the difference between
spending a Visa Card with US dollars on
the other side of it or Euros or another
international currency and using your
Visa card with Bitcoin ether or XRP on
the other side of it what really comes
down to is the source of the currency
itself so when I take my Visa card and
use it at a merchant that's being issued
by a central bank it's being issued by a
government controlled entity if you
happen to live in a place with a
government that you trust you might feel
fine using visa to spend currency from
your own government but a lot of people
around the world don't live in places
with governments that they trust and
they like having a choice to be able to
use this cryptocurrency but until now
spending cryptocurrency was really
difficult for a lot of people you had to
know how to align your wallet with the
merchants wallet the merchants had to be
set up in order to receive it and now
the Visa membership with coinbase
automates all of that so that you don't
even have to think about whether or not
you're spending Bitcoin ether XRP or any
of nine other crypto
currencies and the merchant doesn't have
to be set up to accept any of it all
they have to do is accept pizza for the
viewers who've been paying close
attention you might be looking to call
me out here because coinbase has had a
Visa card for a while now but I want to
encourage you to go online go to the
coin base fees page and scroll all the
way down to the bottom read in the very
fine print you're gonna see that the
coin base card has previously been
issued by a third-party provider called
pay safe now pay safe is one of dozens
if not hundreds of organizations that
make money by doing nothing but giving
others access to the visa Network now
that coin base is a principle member it
has direct access to the visa network
without pay safe or any other third
party bridge but there is a catch you
can spend it anywhere in the world so
long as they accept Visa but you can
only own the card if you're in the
European Union coinbase doing business
with visa like this is part of a bigger
movement within the crypto currency
exchange to expand beyond being a crypto
currency exchange to provide new kinds
of services that were previously only
available from traditional financial
institutions the crypto economy is what
we're driving towards which is it's a
new economy that starts off primarily
online but it's also accessible to
people in emerging markets it's kind of
like more global it's more fair it's
more free it's more efficient there
aren't these like 2% fees every time you
swipe your credit card it's a much more
efficient system so coinbase isn't the
only one who's building these bridges
from crypto to traditional finance and
in fact increasingly we're seeing
traditional finance build bridges to
crypto ranging from insurance companies
to global banks to retailers we're
seeing that same process of removing
unnecessary layers of middlemen of
extracting fat from the financial system
happening across industries and we're
starting to see a future where instead
of crypto overthrowing the traditional
financial system it's strengthening and
removing waste from that system all
while giving people who don't want to
see the old way continue unabated
choice and perhaps that choice is what
this is all going to come down to
[Music]